placebos are about 33 effective on
average
right so this is just the belief that
this pill is going to normalize your
blood sugar or
even start to break down a cancer tumor
or reduce your symptoms of depression
the list goes on and on
about thirty three percent effective on
average and the sibo effect is the
opposite
where you get a negative injunction you
know you'll never walk again
this is incurable you've got six weeks
to live
and these are some of the things that
patients that i've worked with over the
years would hear and also i heard which
was
this is incurable you'll never be able
to live a normal life
and i was relented to be on you know
plethora of drugs
chronic pain but about two years after
that diagnosis
is when i finally had a shift in my
belief system which ultimately all
change comes from that
and i just decided to get well which i'd
never thought about before
you know because i believed that i
couldn't get well